You have said that society
Galicia is not a right-wing society,
but the match
has been an absolute majority for 14 years.
Why does he keep winning
eh?
Galician society is not a Catalan society,
is it?
In fact we can see,
we have 1 level of social mobilization
which is one of the most important in the entire Spanish state.
Also because there is
1 nationalist central as is the CIA
which is the First Trade Union Center.
We have 1 superpowerful feminist movement.
If we go to other electoral processes
we see how the popular party does not win.
It is that the Pepe
it governs it in 1 of the 7 cities of galiza.
and in the main towns of our country.
They do not have the mayoralties.
It is true that they eh go doped in the elections,
have the crtvega at their services
that have made public television
in its propaganda apparatus.
And it is not only the Venega denounces it,
who also denounces journalists,
also means that more than 300
Friday protesting against manipulation.
If you watch the news of the Galician
is that you say telepepé,
is a real scandal
and now we are going to 1 election campaign
in which they are also
using public resources
to campaign pure,
hard,
blatant.
They have already had
in quite a few reprimands from the electoral board
and with everything,
I don't think it will reach them.
because in Galicia we are tired and tired
to see how the country is going less and less
we have less industry,
we have fewer young people,
more than 200,000 emigrants,
we have our healthcare system which is in 1 critical situation.
If you liked this content,
help us!